All right, so this is where normally I put
up the dozens of emails that I get saying
mean
things like David, I can tell that you are
a shill for Elizabeth Warren because when
her polling goes up, you talk about it.
But when her polling goes down, you don't
talk about it.
Or David, I can tell you hate Bernie because
when Bernie's polling goes up, you don't talk
about it.
And when Bernie's polling goes down, you gleefully
talk about it.
And of course, none of that's true, but when
you look at the facts, the truth is we've
had essentially six straight months of Bernie's
polling going more or less nowhere.
He was at 14 in late April and he was at 14
three weeks ago.
Well, we've had six straight months of Elizabeth
Warren's polling, climbing from eight in April
to as high as 27 a couple of weeks ago.
I just tell you what is happening.
And for the first time in many months, Bernie's
polling is showing signs of life.
So is P Buddha judges.
But we'll get to that shortly.
Uh, and it's happening at the expense of Joe
Biden.
And Elizabeth Warren.
Let's look at the numbers for which I am of
course merely a humble messenger, not the
pollster.
Uh, as you can see at the top of the graph
declines for Joe Biden and Elizabeth Warren.
Joe Biden down about two and a half points
in the last three weeks.
Although Elizabeth Warren also losing some
momentum down about five points in the last
three weeks.
Who is gaining in the last three weeks?
Well, it's Bernie and also Pete Buddha judge.
You see Bernie, the blue line popping up from
about 14 to now more than 17, a three point
gain for Bernie.
You also see the purple line on the graph.
This is Pete booted, judge mayor Pete from
South bend, Indiana, climbing from just about
four points a couple of weeks ago now, polling
about 7%.
This is the highest Pete Buddha judge has
pulled since early may.
Otherwise things are basically unchanged.
Camila Harris continuing a more or less slow
decline since early July.
Uh, everything else really not, not much else.
Uh, going on with her.
Uh, Andrew Yang still has his two and a half
average Tulsi Gabbard has her 1.3 average.
Beto still has around two and club char around
two.
So what do we make of all this?
Well, Bernie is still in it.
That's what we make of at Bernie's doing what
he has to do.
If he wants a shot at this thing, gaining
back some of the support that he lost all
the way back in April when Joe Biden entered
this race, if you were supporting Bernie,
you should be pleased.
He did what he had to do in the last three
weeks, which is he picked up three points
in three weeks.
Now with a debate number five coming up, he
has to keep it going and it's particularly
important because we have this fifth debate
coming up on November 20th.
It is an opportunity conceivably, hypothetically
for someone to make a big showing and make
a gain in the polls.
But as I said, when I appeared on PBS a couple
of weeks ago, the further into the primary
we get, the less that there is to gain from
having a good debate showing because the candidates
positions are known, the candidates personalities
are known, the candidates presences presences.
That's a difficult word to say.
Their presences on the stage are known because
they'd been around for longer.
And we've been watching a whole bunch of debates
so far.
So the further we get into this thing, the
debates actually represent a potential liability.
The, the debates represent an opportunity
to do something wrong and to lose support
in the polls.
The downside of the debates becomes bigger
as we get further into it.
Um, particularly because there is less time
to make up for missteps while the possibility
of some big gain due to the debates a diminishes.
So that's just a reality.
That's not about Bernie specifically.
Now for debate number five, we have nine people
already qualified.
We have Beto tool C and Julio on Castro pending
some of the requirements.
So we could conceivably end up with 12 people
on the debate stage again, which, uh, I guess
it diminishes the speaking time for each person,
which in a sense reduces the possibility that
they make some major gaffer fo pot and put
their foot in their mouth.
But once again, we are not going to get deep
discussion about any issue quite frankly.
Um, from a debate that has 12 people up on
the stage, the qualification period for debate
five, which is on November 20th, ends on November
13th the week before.
So they basically have two weeks left to either
be in or out a Beto tools C and M, uh, Julio
on Castro.
So we will see ultimately who makes that stage.
Bernie Sanders, people who are following Bernie
supporting Bernie should be pleased.
Appoint a week.
I mean, listen, Elizabeth Warren got to her
peak of 27 point whatever it was gaining,
uh, about, um, a point and a half to two points
a month.
So of a point a week is a lot.
We haven't had polls for about five days and
I'm guessing by tomorrow we'll have some new
ones.
And we
will
see
how
Bernie is doing there.